[Music]
although there is evidence of potential
violations of the statutes regarding the
handling of classified information our
judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case all
right that was then FBI director James
Comey that was back in 2016 announcing
that the girl would not recommend
charges for Hillary Clinton a decision
that is now under new scrutiny tonight
after two US senators have revealed that
Comey drafted a statement clearing
Clinton well before the investigation
was over and he is now on the phone
retired assistant FBI director for the
New York field office James Kallstrom
and the chief counsel for the American
Center for Law and Justice and president
Trump's attorney Jay Sekulow mr.
Kallstrom let me start with you if you
haven't concluded the investigation how
is it possible you haven't even
interviewed the the person involved how
do you start drafting what Comey was
drafting which is her exoneration well
it was it was clear to me but I think
it's clear to everyone now that
basically he's been carrying water you
know for the Clinton folks Obama
everybody the whole thing was a farce I
mean as soon as you know there's no
grand jury as soon as you know you can't
compel testimony you can't compel you
can't get records you you know you can't
take computers for searching you can't
do any of that stuff it's a it's a farce
the whole thing was the frost from the
beginning
FBI agents don't like to be part of
forces yeah Jay Sekulow let me let me
ask from your standpoint yep because I
think this is this is so important
especially in light of the special
counsel which was James commis goal
after he leaked information of the New
York Times which in itself may have been
illegal in terms of the Records Act and
other other issues he's involved in but
33,000 deleted subpoenaed emails acid
watch a wash bleach pit destruction of
of information on on BlackBerry's and
iPhones why do I think that I'd be
calling you if I did any one of these
things because I'd be in jail for
obstructing justice and violating the
law
because James Comey had a predetermined
outcome of where this was going he said
that in the information that senators
Grassley and Senator Graham said very
clearly that the information they were
already writing up their exoneration
their declination letter as it's called
regarding criminality this was before 16
witnesses are interviewed and before the
target of the matter as James Comey was
told to call it was even interviewed so
what Jim said was right this was a faux
investigation from the start and the
problem is it's really been a fraud on
the American people here this whole
scenario of James commies actions and
his statements before Congress we're not
only incorrect as a matter of fact but I
think puts him in serious legal jeopardy
is this now Jay open up the possibility
that the Attorney General should now get
to the truth considering I think this
reveals more than anything else that the
fix was in for Hillary and James Comey
was a violent look I think James Comey
needs to be the subject of what son
investigation as to what's going on here
I mean look at the evidence I mean this
information is damaging to say the least
it puts the whole investigation or
whatever you want to call what was going
on there really a sideshow is what it
ended up being it puts the whole matter
as they like to call it into perspective
it was never intended to be an
investigation in the first place and
James Comey was part about yeah that's
what James Cummins Kallstrom I James the
law is even it's even worse than that
you know call me you know this whole
business of the so-called phony Russian
investigation you know that's all to
sidetrack the president so he can't
can't have his appointment she can't he
can't deal with anything else it's all
Comey you know playing Act two of a
farce basically last last quick question
you know we I've interviewed Julian
Assange he said that it was not rush I
have interviewed him five times
now dana rohrabacher believes him does
robert muller james Kallstrom in your
opinion have an obligation to talk to
the one guy on this earth that would
know for sure if that the DNC emails
didn't come from Russia
Mulla should never be the special
counsel he's got he's got a conflict of
interest a mile wide he was he and
combing your buddies I mean it's just
preposterous that the Deputy Attorney
General
number one the point of special counsel
number two appointed mullah of all
people i measures outrageous should yet
should he investigate yes no I think so
too
jo Shan I think it offensive by the way
I think the deploy think the Department
of Justice can do that as relates to
James Comey I think the Department of
you not to have a special counsel for
Justice needs to find out about and do
the right inappropriate investigation
with the grand jury as to the leaking of
a conversation that James Comey had with
the President of the United States I
would start with that and then work
backwards to the fact that he
predetermined the outcome of the other
investigation or so-called investigation
but but let's start with the littlest
leak started a leak from the President
of the United States a statement that
James Comey had with the president the
United States he leaked to a friend of
his to leak to the press that's
inexcusable it should be investigated
all right thank you all important things
we'll stay on it no